sometimes you just want to feel that
electricity of like I'm gonna go outside
today and I'm gonna get away with this
I hesitate to talk about my style as if
it's anything that I think about beyond
the moment of what feels right I
certainly have not congealed this
thinking into like I am a style guy like
I don't normally do these interviews
talking about fashion I know that we're
heading towards this place culturally
were like people who aren't necessarily
always thought of as style people have
become that which i think is super fun
[Music]
my style is about balance between these
highly differentiating novel interesting
far-out things and working in a new kind
of a daily wear situation I really am
seeing what I can get away with without
making people go like oh come on I'm
sort of committed myself to some extent
to always being in that zone of
something that makes people go what but
then the fun part for me is finding a
balance and then when you get away with
it you want to do something else that
makes someone else go well now what is
that I got turned on to visit him in
like 2005 2005 you'd go to Japan and
your cell phone wouldn't work and that
was really exciting and you would rely
on the kindness of the friends who knew
other people in Japan to sort of tell
you where to go
and I was walked into this van by a
friend of a friend you know like guys
who really have it going on at house
your clean stuff and I really was into
the fact that everything that Hiroki
made had this one differentiating
element to it
pieces that have come to be associated
with me are like rose I think I've
always liked the robes because it
doesn't fit spiritually when you put it
on the description of a jacket or a
shirt becomes sort of like a rune hard
to explain is a real power to
[Music]
you have a certain number of points you
can spend on an outfit let's say you
up-tempo wearing a robe is an instant
6-pointer and if you're gonna wear
something that's hyperbole you're
spending most your points you better go
jeans and t-shirt personally I like to
keep it at 10 I'm starting to go a
little more starting to go like
sometimes I'm ending off like eight or
nine points leave in that and I think
that's an age thing man I do feel like
with my age and the number of years that
I've been dressing myself that I
definitely have like fallen into it do's
and don'ts for me personally so I feel
like I am at the end of a era of a lot
of mistakes you know I feel like your
20s and your 30s should be like figure
it out
and then when you get in your 40s you're
like yo here's what works I'm like man
look at the pictures of you from your
20s in your early 30s people are working
that out to every person in their 20s
and their 30s wear that hat people are
very like shoes people see shoes is the
main event I see a shoe is a stabilizing
force in an outfit people were always
doing the switcheroo on the latest
greatest shoe I wish more people myself
included would just wear one thing into
the rap I'm gonna see repeats I think
repeats are cool there's a thing that
you won't know unless you live in
something for so long that every day you
put your foot in it it's just forming to
your foot to wear any other shoe or boot
is like wrong when you finally get to a
point
where it becomes something like somebody
would describe in your personal life as
a John thing to where you're getting
somewhere the end of the day I'm still
just a dude and buys a bunch of stuff
tries it on as soon as I get it
leaves a pile on the closet floor and
works with whatever Kent comes of that
you know there's just a do two buys a
bunch of clothes
it's figured out his own sort of code
for putting them on lest anyone think
that this has become too precious
it's the do Tobias bunch of clothes
aren't we all we're all just people who
buy a bunch of clothes and when we put a
certain combination on we feel a little
bit greater than we did before
[Music]